cette semaine on s'intéresse à la bande
dessinée et plus particulièrement au
manga d'après une étude publiée par le
centre national du livre près de 43 %
des adultes lisent au moins une bande
dessinée par an et ce chiffre monte à
77% chez les enfants sur le podium des
titres les plus plébiscités on retrouve
astérix tintin et one piece ou one piece
est un manga japonais dont le 95e tome a
été publié cet été en france ce qui est
un signe de son succès absolument
phénoménale le manga connu son essor à
la fin des années 90 dans notre pays et
depuis il est parfaitement inséré sur le
marché au point que des auteurs français
se soit approprié ce style japonais
c'est le cas de christophe pointeau
l'auteur de wind freighters édité chez
glénat que nous avons rencontrés c'est
un auteur du loiret alors comment on
devient tous auteurs de manga en france
et quels sont ses inspirations voici le
premier épisode de cette série les yeux
c'est le plus important même si l'oeil
sont fermés un quart de millimètre dans
le sourcil dans le placement de liu quoi
ça change tout dans lâché christophe
coin tôt la peur de la page blanche a
vite disparu
auteur prolifique il publie depuis juin
dernier sa deuxième série wind fighters
chez glénat dont le tome 2 est sorti au
mois d'octobre wind fighters a alors que
le régime impose sa loi d'une main de
fer
seuls les wind fighters pourront faire
souffler un nouveau vent de liberté
comme de nombreux fans de manga en
france christophe est très fan du style
shônen des mangas d' aventure qui
suivent l'évolution d'un personnage à
travers des combats comme dragon ball ou
naruto des titres cultes qui l'inspirent
et qu'il accompagne tous les jours c'est
ma nourriture visuel j'ai besoin d'être
entouré de
de tout ça pour pour me dire voilà je
suis dans la bonne place pour créer je
suis dans le dans la bonne humeur ça
c'est vraiment ça donne une énergie en
fait donc c'est très important pour moi
après l'inspiration elle vient elle
vient vraiment de la vie de tous les
jours de ce que je vois de ce que
j'observe du monde de ce que j'ai vécu
mois de mai de ce qui me parle en fait
de mes envies puisque quand on crée une
histoire c'est quelque chose qui vient
de nous donc il faut que ce soit assez
personnelle passée par l'école d'art
d'angoulême
christophe s'élancer pleinement il y a
dix ans dans cette carrière il s'est
autofinancé ses premiers mangas avant
d'être repéré par glénat et de publié
six livres en deux ans une cadence très
soutenue dans le manga impose un rythme
assez élevé puisque etc des tonnes de
200 pages et il faut en faire minimum 1
voire 2 par an pour pouvoir exister
entre guillemets dans le marché
donc ça représente vraiment voilà un
impératif de pages probablement un peu
plus élevé que dans dans la bande
dessinée franco belge kristof voilà ce
que j'ai retrouvé leur faisait le ménage
dans la maison
regarde c'est comme souvent c'est durant
l'enfance que l' envie de dessiner s'est
fait ressentir et depuis le trait a bien
évolué
si le métier d'auteur de manga koné des
hauts et des bas christophe peut compter
sur le soutien de sa famille je me dis
je crois en toi je sais que les métiers
justement de dessinateurs de les métiers
d'art c'est pas des métiers où on peut
espérer gagner beaucoup d'argent tout de
suite mais je préfère le voir heureux
avec peu d'argent plutôt que malheureux
enfermés derrière un bureau
voilà je sais que ça serait ça serait
pas là où il s'épanouit et je veux dit
s'épanouissent pour autant pas le temps
de se reposer sur ses lauriers
à peine le tome 2 sorties que les
planches du tome iii sont attendus par
son éditeur